on this saturday night
the supreme court showdown donald trump
names his conservative nominee judge amy
coney barrett
what she stands for and the push to get
her a seat on america's most powerful
court
an emotional plea to canadian
politicians i don't want to stand for
anybody else a dad breaks down after his
children were barred from crossing into
canada
to say goodbye to their dying mother
pandemic policies
insurance for those trying to get away
despite the warnings against
travel and sir david attenborough
gets social this is my first time
on instagram the 94 year old breaks the
record
to inspire change
global national with robin gill
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us u.s president donald trump sparked a
10th standoff tonight
after picking his nominee for the
supreme court late today
trump named judge amy coney barrett as
his candidate
a favorite among republican
conservatives largely because she
supports the religious right
today it is my honor to nominate one of
our nation's most brilliant
and gifted legal minds to the supreme
court
she is a woman of unparalleled
achievement
towering intellect sterling credentials
and unyielding loyalty to the
constitution
judge amy coney barrett
trump is trying to force the
confirmation before the november
election
the president's push to fill the vacancy
and today's announcement has
outraged democrats who say the move will
alter the ideological makeup of
america's most
powerful court for years here's jennifer
johnson
if confirmed by the u.s senate judge amy
coney barrett
would cement a conservative majority on
the u.s supreme court
replacing one of its most outspoken
liberals justice ruth bader ginsburg
supreme court justices serve lifetime
appointments at 48 years old barrett
would be the youngest justice
and could help reshape the law for
generations to come
hopefully we'll be on that court for 50
years
a claim that ignited trump supporters at
a campaign rally friday night
barrett a devout catholic widely backed
by evangelicals
is a married mother of seven she is
considered to be anti-abortion
and against same-sex marriage many fear
if she's confirmed
the country's landmark roe v wade
decision giving women the right to
abortion
would be in jeopardy in 2016 barrett
predicted a conservative court
wouldn't overturn roe but put more
limits on abortions
i don't think the the core case that
rose core holding that you know women
have a right to an abortion i don't
think that would change but i think the
question of
whether people can get very late term
abortions you know how many restrictions
can be put on clinics i think that would
change barrett had already been vetted
by the white house before the president
decided to nominate judge brett
kavanaugh in july 2018.
her nomination now goes to the
republican-controlled u.s senate
which will move quickly on her
confirmation hearing i believe it is
critical
that we confirm that nominee before
election day
i believe we will have the votes to do
that and get it done barrett could
possibly be seated in time to rule on
lawsuits
arising from the presidential election
should president trump lose and question
the validity of millions of mail-in
ballots
democrats are vowing to fight her
confirmation as they did in 2017
after the president nominated her to
serve on the federal appeals court
dogma lives loudly within you
and that's of concern but right now
democrats don't have enough votes to
stop barrett from taking a seat
on america's highest court jennifer
johnson global news
washington the border closure has caused
thousands of canadians to be separated
from loved ones
today they held a virtual rally in hopes
of convincing the federal government to
do more to reunite families
david aiken has the heartbreaking story
of two americans who couldn't say
goodbye to their dying mother
a canadian it's been more than 40 years
since
john and donna mccall fell in love got
married and started a family
john an american donna a canadian the
kids born near chicago had only
us citizenship that was never an issue
until march when canada closed the
border
only canadians and essential workers
would be allowed in
john and donna about to retire near
peterborough ontario
were separated from the kids still in
the states
and when donna became seriously ill
earlier this year and
john needed help caring for her the
canadian rules prevented the american
kids
from helping their canadian mom the
family pressed ottawa for a
compassionate exemption but
none came in early august in hospital
the decision was made to remove donna
from life support
i called the kids and i held the phone
up and they said goodbye
it's tough i don't want this to happen
anybody else it's a tragedy that
shouldn't have happened
donna had spent a career as a nurse and
was remembered as one
who taught caregivers about the power of
compassion
she taught them how to be a
compassionate nurse and then for her to
be treated with so
little compassion by this government is
very hard to take
mccall and 7 200 other canadians are
now part of a group called faces of
advocacy
it is pressing the federal government to
change the rules
that could help thousands of families
like john's
every minute that it's delayed is a
minute that some family is going without
being together at a critical time and
those minutes might not be there
on saturday mccall spoke to an online
rally organized by the group and
mps from all parties also spoke in favor
of those rule changes
i don't understand why this is taking so
long we know we can do this safely we
know
that we can we can relieve such such
stress such anguish such difficulties
for people
there are obvious compassionate cases
that should have been fixed
many many many weeks ago and it looks
like the government is ready to move
erskine smith said changes are expected
to be announced
next week changes though that will have
come
too late for john mccall david aiken
global news
ottawa now to the covet 19 picture in
canada
there have been more than 150 000
confirmed cases
including more than 9 000 deaths quebec
is reporting 698 new coven 19 cases
today
that's the highest single day tally
since may
ontario posted 435 new cases in the last
24 hours
the bulk of them in toronto canadians
are being discouraged from international
travel so many are turning to domestic
trips no matter where you plan to
vacation insurance experts have some
advice
heather yorks west explains western
canadian ski resorts are gearing up for
what they hope will be
a busy winter all of our visitors
obviously this summer were
from canada so we've been reaching out
to canadians and certainly we were
fortunate that we are located in the
mountains and
and that offers what canadians i think
are really needing and that's wide open
spaces
with no nearby faces winter escapes have
always been popular among canadians
but this year a sunny locale may be out
of reach
ottawa is still recommending against all
non-essential travel
and insurance experts warn that advisory
can limit potential coverage
in general travel insurance will cover
you
when the government of canada doesn't
have
a level 3 or a level 4
on the destination but soon companies
like
manulife will begin offering so-called
pandemic policies
providing coverage for medical and even
quarantine expenses for destinations
regardless of a government travel
advisory it's a very difficult
ethical situation right now and business
situation you've got airlines
and tour operators and insurance
companies
that are struggling and may go out of
business
if they don't start to generate new
business and yet at the same time
these companies are going against
government recommendations
and experts warn that if travelers
become seriously ill with the virus
while traveling
these policies may not cover all
expenses particularly if patients
require icu care or a ventilator
many policies offer coverage up to the
millions of dollars range so two to five
million
so uh you would have to be gravely ill
which as we know with this virus is not
out of the realm of possibility
there are fewer restrictions for
canadians wishing to travel between
provinces this winter
so a travel insurance policy may be
worthwhile
if you're involved in an accident or
where you have a medical emergency where
you're in a remote location and an air
ambulance or a helicopter has to come
and pick you up in order to get you
to a tertiary hospital where you need
advanced medical care
that can be very very expensive and
there's also the chance that surprise
covid19
symptoms could leave you with no choice
but to cancel
fortunately insurance providers are now
offering coverage for those things
too as the travel industry adapts to the
new
reality heather urex west global news
calgary
the canada emergency response benefit
expires today but next week parliament
is expected to debate
new legislation to provide support for
workers that's one of several
big-ticket promises from the liberal
government on this week's west block our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
looks into whether the government can
deliver
mercedes covid19 may still be relatively
new but the liberal's latest throne
speech is taking aim at concerns
that have been around for decades the
government is pledging to bring in
a national child care program and to
take quicker steps to deliver
universal pharmacare but with the
federal deficit already pushing
400 billion dollars i asked canada's
deputy prime minister and finance
minister
if she is concerned about the country's
economic future
here's what she had to say we are having
to spend
extraordinary amounts of money to fight
this pandemic
and yes that does mean as finance
minister
i am very concerned and i believe there
is a tremendous
onus on us the federal government to be
very careful
to be very thoughtful to be very prudent
about these extraordinary expenditures
meanwhile provincial and territorial
leaders are pushing the federal
government to spend even more
the premiers are asking ottawa to put an
extra 70
billion dollars in to cover health care
costs manitoba premier brian pallister
told me it's time for the federal
government
to step up when it comes to health care
this is an emerging
long-term problem it's worsened over
years now and it's going to get worse
more and more canadians are experiencing
this personally
and we need to address it and we can't
just put it off
another year or two or five it's going
to get
worse and as it gets worse real people
friends of yours and mine are going to
be impacted and we're going to be the
ones who didn't stand up for health care
i don't think so
pallister says now is not the time for
short-term thinking as he calls it
and he wants to see the federal
government become what he says would be
a real partner in health care we'll dig
into that story more on the west block
all right thanks mercedes we are
witnessing a surge of coven 19
around the world there are more than 32
million cases globally
and the death toll is nearing 1 million
cases are rising fast in brazil where
140 000 people have died
there are more than 5 million infections
in india which has the second highest
number of cases
in the world the u.s is still the
hardest hit
more than 7 million people there have
been infected
in the uk police broke up a protest in
central london because
thousands of demonstrators were not
social distancing many weren't wearing
masks either
at least 10 people were arrested the
protesters are upset with new measures
to curb the spread of the virus
among the new rules a 10 pm curfew for
restaurants and bars
mandatory face masks for staff in the
hospitality and retail sectors
and fines if these measures aren't
followed
coming up the confession from the main
suspect charged with a stabbing outside
the former offices
of charlie hebdo
at least 26 people have been killed in a
plane crash in ukraine
seven crew members and 20 cadets from a
military aviation school were on board
the plane
the antonov plane belonging to the
ukrainian air force crashed as it was
preparing to land
at least one person survived today the
country's president visited the survivor
and hospital
all flights involving the same plane
model have been halted
until the cause of the crash is
determined
in paris police have seven people in
custody after a stabbing outside the
former offices
of satirical newspaper charlie hebdo a
man
and a woman who worked for a documentary
production company were attacked
yesterday with a meat cleaver
the main suspect apparently told
investigators he did it because he was
angry the newspaper had recently
republished caricatures of the prophet
muhammad
the incident is being investigated as an
act of terrorism
in 2015 12 people were gunned down when
islamic extremists targeted
charlie hebdo's offices lebanon's prime
minister designate has stepped down
after less than a month on the job his
resignation delays the prospect of
getting any foreign economic assistance
that's needed to rescue the country from
collapse mustapha adib says it became
clear to him
that he could not line up a nonpartisan
cabinet
he had tried to form a government in a
nation where power is shared between
muslims and christians
and political loyalties tend to follow
sectarian lines
hadib won the support of lebanon's major
political parties in august
the previous government resigned amid
widespread anger
over the blast in beirut's port that
killed at least
200 people still ahead surviving yemen's
long-running civil war
with covet 19.
the civil war in yemen has claimed the
lives of so many civilians
and as the conflict enters its sixth
year the reliance on humanitarian aid is
more critical than ever before
the united nations warns supplies are
being cut
or purposely held back as mike armstrong
reports
on top of famine and conflict yemen is
also facing
the pandemic
there is no part of life in yemen not
affected by what the world health
organization calls
the catastrophic humanitarian disaster
for kidney dialysis patients even
sitting in the hospital hooked up to the
dialysis machine
doesn't mean safety
as soon as i get here i face a bigger
problem this man says the machine stops
because there's no electricity
the problem is hospitals don't have fuel
to run
generators the fuel shortage in yemen is
worsening by the day
prices have doubled and fuels being
rationed drivers can spend
not hours but days in line to get their
maximum
40 liters per week
how can i work asks this taxi driver how
can i feed myself and my kids
now fuel imports have become a weapon in
the six-year conflict houthi rebels
backed by iran seized power in 2014
they control much of the northwest while
a saudi-led coalition supporting the
former government controls much of the
rest
well 70 percent of the country's
commercial goods come through a port
city on the red sea
controlled by the coalition the houthis
say since the summer
even u.n cleared commercial ships are
being held
back as a form of economic warfare
their response the houthis have closed
the airport and the capital to u.n
and humanitarian flights according to
oxfam that's meant 200 metric tons of
aid
can't reach the people who need it the
u.n this week called for the immediate
reopening of the airport
well uh things are very dire according
to this oxfam spokesperson the situation
in yemen is worsening by the day
he says civilians have been stuck
between two warring sides
20 million people are now food insecure
in june 28 percent of families in the
houthi-controlled areas didn't have
enough to eat
just three months later that's up to 43
percent
the aid blocked at the airport is needed
desperately
there are many many people who are
in critical need for such assistance and
more delays would mean more people will
lose their lives
on top of the conflict yemen has one of
the highest covet 19 death rates in the
world the red cross did open a new covid
19 clinic in the southern part of the
country this week
but testing and reporting are low and
the health care system is on the verge
of collapse
there's fear many are simply staying
home dying there
and their cases are going unreported
mike armstrong global news
up next the canines tasked with sniffing
out kobit 19.
my name is david attenborough and i've
been appearing
on radio and television
and now he's on instagram at 94 years
old the legendary broadcaster is
bringing the natural world to the app
in his first post sir attenborough says
saving our planet
is now a communications challenge in
trying to fix the world
he broke a world record the fastest time
to reach
1 million followers he did that in 4
hours
and 44 minutes that beat jennifer
aniston's record by 32 minutes
even the duke and duchess of sussex took
5 hours and 45 minutes to reach 1
million
before that the fastest time was just
under 12 hours
for k-pop star kang daniel the pope
himself
took half a day to get to 1 million
double that
for david beckham an airport in finland
is
experimenting with a real time covert 19
testing method
using dogs the pilot project has trained
canines to sniff out the coronavirus
as crystal commansing explains this
program could be a game changer when it
comes to air travel
during the pandemic the power of a dog's
nose has long been a lifesaver
trained to sniff out survivors and
rubble find
bombs even detect an epileptic seizure
before it strikes
finland is the first european country
deploying dogs to screen people for
covet 19
in an airport we come close to 100
percent
of sensitivity and and
they are actually not doing exactly the
same as the pcr test because the pcr
test needs a certain quantity
to be positive that high accuracy rating
of nearly 100 percent
is in line with other tests in july
german researchers published results of
a study involving eight dogs
after one week of training researchers
say the dogs were able to correctly
identify the canisters containing a
positive sample
94 percent of the time in the uk
a similar project is underway the team
is now looking for people who have
tested positive to donate
samples so the dogs can get to work so
we're
trying to get as many cases as we can
so that we can collect samples of of
smell from them
three ways using face masks using socks
and shirts as well
at the helsinki airport volunteers are
asked to rub a cloth over their neck or
arms a similar test site opened in
august at the dubai international
airport the dogs are trained to give
specific
cues if they detect an odor that is
thought to be unique to people
infected with the virus what we've seen
in our
research is that the dogs actually
will find them about five days
before they get any clinical symptoms
it's it's experimental and
and and i think it's a nice addition to
the this ultimate i would not rule them
out but
i'm a medical professional and i want to
see the data before i
recommend anything more data is needed
and that's why
testing sites like the one in finland
are so important
researchers are also mindful of the
health of the dogs
the trainers say they are closely
monitored and no one wants a family
member
human or canine to test positive
crystal gomansing global news london
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is the south
saskatchewan river in saskatoon
good night